before we begin this episode let's take
a brief moment of silence for those that
died this episode
brienne's virginity rhaegal tormund and
gendry's heart
miss and i and now back to our regularly
scheduled programming
the episode begins on our lord of the
friend zone sir jorah mormont getting
the first and only kiss he'll get from
daenerys targaryen but in this scene we
never get to see what dany whispers into
his
ear so lip readers out there i need to
hear from you
sansa gives theon his redemption by
giving him a house stark pin
and honestly we need to ask ourselves if
theon is worthy of this redemption
he did some pretty despicable things to
house stark including burning children
and watching sansa's rape but on the
other hand he did stand up for house
stark and join them in the battle
eventually losing his life in the
process so do we like mr no balls or
should we let him
die redemptionless and yes
redemptionless isn't a word
jon says some last goodbyes saying our
last duty is to keep the dead ones alive
in our memories
and our heroes burn the dead paying
homage to the sacrifice they made in
protecting the realm
from the night king a particular note is
sam birding edison and arya burning
barrack both of whom sacrificed
themselves in order so that they could
survive but the biggest side eye of the
evening belongs to danny and john who
both have unsettled business on who will
become the true king
of the seven kingdoms gendry has a
heartfelt conversation with the hound
who believes gendry has only one thing
on his mind
but as gendry makes his way to the front
he's given the title of lord gendry
baratheon of storm ends
being the last of the baratheon line
this is a calculated move by dany who
knows that gendry will now be loyal to
her
dany knows that with the end of the
white walkers the game of thrones is
still
on and of course davos is the first one
to pledge his allegiance
jaime pours some wine for brienne
looking to get lucky and let me say
it works out we've been waiting seasons
for this people
perhaps one of the most insightful
comments of the episode takes place
between davos and tyrion
in which tyrion says we may have killed
the white walkers but we still have
us to contend with it brings question to
who
the real evil is the monsters or
ourselves
tyrion tells bran he'll be lord of
winterfell and the most important
part of this conversation is bran
telling him he shouldn't be because he
mostly lives
in the past i think we'll come back to
this in episodes to come
because there's more to bran in the
overall game of thrones narrative
than we've been led on to believe then
we get a whole bunch of toasts including
tormund who acts like a drunk bro
and the sexiest game of truth or dare
between jaime and brienne
tormund sticks up for jon calling him a
tiny man who even though he died and was
resurrected
keeps fighting this type of talk pisses
off dany who's like
how can i compete against not only the
rightful heir to the throne
but someone who is beloved amongst the
people then the most important part of
this whole
episode brienne is a virgin extra virgin
jamie goes after brienne leaving tormund
whose unrequited love is noticed by
tyrion and pod
but don't worry guys tormund will find a
woman you can touch me
i'm not afraid of wildlings clegane
however
isn't too receptive of women and that's
due in large part that his character arc
isn't complete he still has to leave
winterfell and take on his brother
in cleganebowl when sansa asks what will
make him happy
he replies it's his own effing business
my guess is that there will be an
epic battle between clegane and the
mountain likely resulting in his death
but a redemptive arc
and now for the saddest part of this
episode and no i don't mean missandei
gendry pledges his love to arya as the
new lord of storm's
end and wants her to be his lady but
remember
arya is no lady she gives him one last
kiss telling him he'll be a wonderful
lord
he's shot down harder than rhaegal but
it's ultimately appropriate for arya's
character
a drunken jaime interrupts brand for
yes it's only taken us like six seasons
but maybe there's a brand baby in the
oven who will be the fiercest fighter
ever seen in westeros and there's
nothing that turns on a queen more than
talking about her friend's own boy who
died literally a few hours ago but
there's still
some unfinished business dany believes
herself to be queen but jon is the
rightful heir
he's so enamored with her he'll refuse
all rights to the throne and dany gives
him an ultimatum
he must swear bran and samwell to
secrecy
in order for her to retain the throne to
me this scene is the end of dany
her lust for power will be the end of
her she believes this truth will be the
end of them but doesn't realize it could
be their greatest strength
it's this belief that will likely result
in her death at the end of the season
unless she changes her way but this is
the line that does it for danny
we can
i've just told you how it's that kind of
[ __ ] danny that's gonna make you
dead
in the war room greyworm and john tell
that half the unsullied
northmen and dothraki are gone now with
the golden company in king's landing the
tides have turned in cersei's favor
the plan is to surround king's landing
and make the refugees fight against
cersei
jon and sir davos will take the
remaining unsullied northern troops and
dothraki while tyrion and a smaller
force
will travel to white harbor with the
queen and the dragons
jaime will remain in winterfell with his
boo brienne
something tells me he'll be making his
way to king's landing eventually to take
on the queen
arya and sansa tell jon they don't trust
danny trying to sway his emotions but
jon doesn't want to go back on his word
with danny
and tell them the truth about his
heritage instead he's a little [ __ ] and
makes bran do it
technically not going against his
promise to dany
jaime knows that brienne is sworn to
protect the stark girl hence why he's
staying in winterfell
but this beautiful brother brother scene
is interrupted by brawn
and honestly this scene pissed me off
braun who has established connections
beyond friendship with both of these men
still values
money and prestige over his own
integrity
he even makes a deal with them and
leaves thinking after holding a crossbow
to them
that they'll honor it after he's done
braun is so idiotic and this scene is
such a slap in the face to bronze
character arc that i was left
dumbfounded hey look it's ari in the
hound traveling on the road once again
he reiterates that if he gets hurts
she'll just leave him again
and that's love folks tyrion tries to
convince sansa that dany will be a good
queen
and that with jon in the south she'll be
the true power in the north but sansa
isn't quite
having it she tells him what if there is
someone else
someone better likely referring to jon
being the rightful king since bran would
have told her the truth several scenes
ago
tormund is bringing the free folk back
home mainly because the women here don't
agree with him
and can we just take a moment to talk
about ghost jon doesn't even get a good
buy with him
this doggo helped killed the white
walkers and doesn't even get a head
scratch or a good boy
well i don't agree with that but at
least jon gets to say goodbye to gilly
and sam and sam
got it in my boy sam putting a bun in
the oven and there's even a heartfelt
scene between the two
you're the best friend i ever had
[Music]
you too sir oh and look at these
sweethearts if only they knew what's to
come tyrion tells varys that the secret
about jon and dany is
already out this already puts in plans
in varys mind as how an eventual
shift in power would work but before
this can even happen they still need
to take on cersei and capture king's
landing but as we get this beautiful
sweeping shot of dany riding on our
dragons
rhaegal is brutally shot down by euron
and his iron fleet
each ship has giant crossbows which
almost take down dany and drogon in the
process
but danny knows she's no match and
eventually retreats
euron focuses his powers on the
remaining targaryen fleet
which proves devastating for the queen
and her armies
very centurion wash ashore with greyworm
searching for his love
unfortunately for missandei she's been
taken prisoner
with the usurper coming people flee into
king's landing fearing her and her
dragons will obliterate the countryside
cersei is actually using the people as a
bargaining chip
if dany is to take over king's landing
she'll have to risk killing
innocent civilians in the process
furthermore cersei tells euron that
their child will eventually rule
over the seven kingdoms something that
will come into question in the scenes to
come
it's here we see that misondi has been
captured and will eventually be used as
a bargaining chip as well
varys echoes the feeling that tens of
thousands of civilians will die if dany
attacks king's landing head head-on with
drogon
and her troops but dany isn't having it
she's here to free the world from
tyrants whatever the cost another remark
foreshadowing that dany won't end up on
the throne in the end
varys himself even starts to
second-guess daenerys stating to tyrion
if he's ever wondered the best person to
rule as someone who never wanted to rule
in the first place
aka jon this talk of treason turns
tyrion off he believes that nanny and
jon could rule together
but varys isn't too sure of that tyrion
will believe in dany no matter what and
varys will believe in the realm no
matter what how this will play out will
be
interesting in the episodes to come
jaime gets the news that euron has
killed one of dany's dragons and
captured missandei
it's clear he's fighting between staying
with brienne and continuing his true
destiny of finishing off his sister
it's my theory that jaime will be the
one to finally kill
cersei not the hound and not arya
brienne tells him he's a good man
and can't save cersei pleading that he
stays there with her
but he refuses he says he's not a good
man all the bad deeds he's done in his
life has been for cersei
and the only way he can redeem himself
from that is to kill her
that's why his arc has only one end
either he kills her
or dies trying outside the gates of
king's landing dany has amassed an army
of
a hundred people this is her attempt to
show the people of king's landing that
she's
actually trying to negotiate qyburn
comes out like the friggin mouth of
sauron
in its hand of the queen versus hand of
the queen in an epic battle
dany demands cersei's unconditional
surrender and release of missandei
but cersei wants daenerys's
unconditional surrender and if she
refuses
missandei will be killed tyrion is sick
of hearing qyburn and engages directly
with cersei
pleading for the sake of her child to
give up and this will have consequences
for euron who believes he's the only one
who knows about the kid
whose baby is it that is if there is a
kid at all cersei isn't having it and
asks missandei what her last words are
to which she replies
dracarus burn it all down and with that
she's killed by the mountain
making both clegane and grey worm fierce
competitors on who's going to take down
the mountain
a woman who spent most of her life in
chains now dies in them
i hope you enjoy this episode and make
sure to like and subscribe because i'll
be coming out with an episode 5
prediction video
and other game of thrones theories you
can follow me on twitter at thinkstoryyt
and remember daddy loves you very much
you